it's a new day in wakanda with a new
face on the throne a new Black Panther
and a fearsome ocean-dwelling new enemy
there's even a new Iron person and
plenty of questions about what's coming
next warning Major Spoilers ahead for
black panther wakanda forever
after King tachaka meets his untimely
end in Captain America Civil War his son
t'challa becomes a new leader of wakanda
in order to make his position official
t'challa goes through a ceremony
involving ritual combat Birds when
t'challa himself dies before the events
of wakanda forever Ramona becomes a
country's leader apparently by default
surely the only other Royal in wakanda
seems fine with this situation as she
prefers to spend her time in the lab but
then ramonda abruptly dies due to
Neymar's actions making sure wakanda's
de facto leader this development is
overshadowed by the fact that shuri also
becomes the Black Panther shortly
afterward it's this super heroic title
she invokes to declare war on Namor and
his people without the Black Panther
wakanda will fall in one of the final
scenes of black panther wakanda forever
the ceremony that solidified t'challa's
leadership is staged once more
indicating that shuri is ready to
officially become Queen but isambaku not
shuri who emerges to take part in the
ritual fans know that embaku has coveted
the throne since the first black panther
film in which he challenges t'challa and
losers but in this case there's no one
there to challenge does that mean embaku
gets the throne by default while shuri
deliberately skips the ceremony it's not
clear if she sends embaku in her place
with the intention of making him King
it's certainly possible juries never
seemed all that interested in leadership
and she might feel that tumbaku is a
better choice for the role But
ultimately the question of who will be
the country's new leader is left open
one of the biggest developments in Black
Panther wakanda forever is the
introduction of Riri Williams a genius
MIT student and the inventor of the
vibranium detection device that the
United States uses to search for the
valuable metal this invention puts us
squarely in Amor's crosses sure you know
Korea travel to America to protect Riri
and soon learn she's created an Iron Man
style suit in her garage when she joins
a fight against Neymar and the talocons
it's mainly to repay her debt to wakanda
for saving her being a superhero long
term doesn't seem to be part of riri's
plans and by the end of the movie she's
on her way back to MIT this surely isn't
the last we'll see of her though for one
thing she's a star of the upcoming
einhardt Disney plus series which
indicates she'll take up the call of a
hero and become an official do-gooder
plus she's one of many young superheroes
introduced in the Marvel Cinematic
universes phase four including America
Chavez Miss Marvel and Kate Bishop
reread seems all but certain to team up
with them as part of a Young Avengers
style group somewhere down the line
Okoye has a life-altering storyline and
black panther wakanda forever not only
is she devastated by t'challa's death
but a frantic Ramona who blames her for
losing Shari to Neymar and the telecons
and Boston fires her from the Dora
milaje and it seems like her Korea does
her best to leave her former life behind
when Ramona dies and sure he comes to
enlist her in the fight against the
telecons Okoye initially seems reluctant
fortunately sure he has an added
incentive a suit she refers to as a
Midnight Angel throughout the film shuri
tried to ghetto Kyrie to accept upgrades
to the Dora melange's armor and weapons
with no real luck but things chained for
nokoye sees shuri's Midnight Angel
prototype Chi along with IO and aneka
were the new suits join the movie's
climatic final battle not only does this
allow Okoye to jump back into action it
also means she's part of a new Elite
fighting unit comic book fans will
recognize the Midnight's angels as a
strike force within the Dora melange in
their very first album melting they take
on the infamous Dr Doom after he steals
wakanda's vibranium could this mean that
okay and the midnight angels will be the
vehicle through which the Fantastic Four
antagonist has introduced to the MCU
possibly here's what we do know the last
we see of Okoye and black panther are
kinda forever she's rescuing agent
Everett Ross from CIA custody entirely
solo likely at shuri's request one way
or another Okoye is once again an
important player in wakanda's Affairs
and could become a more visible figure
in the larger MCU
in Black Panther killmonger Burns all of
the heart-shaped herbs that empower the
Black Panther in an effort to prevent
anyone else from Gaining its impressive
gifts shuri spends most of wakanda
forever attempting to genetically
engineer a new version of the herb and
in Joel's repeated failures but then she
uses a leaf that is part of a gift from
Neymar which turns out to have similar
properties as a heart-shaped herb shuri
discovers how to reconstitute the herb
thanks to this addition and hastily
ingests it making her the New Black
Panther by the end of the film wakandans
are planting the newly reborn
heart-shaped herb ensuring they have a
supply for future or condom protectors
in many ways shuri's decision to become
the Black Panther makes sense based on
wakanda's history she is the nation's
current leader and the leader and black
panther are often the same person though
this is not necessarily a requirement
plus shuri has repeatedly proven herself
a capable fighter when the need arises
only the most broken people can get rare
leaders however by the end of the film
her desire to stay on the wakandan
throne is in question shuri's greatest
skill remains as scientific genius and
their Sterling technological advances
that enables her to create it's possible
that shuri could abdicate her
responsibility as the leader of wakanda
or at least share the duties with
another maybe the role of the ruler and
black panther could split allowing the
latter to focus on the day-to-day
protection of the nation if embaku
becomes king would he allows such an
arrangement
CIA agent Everett Ross is drawn into the
plot of black panther wakanda forever
when Okoye and shuri travel to America
and approach him for the name of the
individual who created the vibranium
detecting device while Ross is reluctant
to share the information he eventually
relents because of his ongoing loyalty
to the wakandans by giving up the name
he commits a crime against the United
States unfortunately for him it's only a
matter of time before the CIA director
discovers his treachery the fact that
the CIA director happens to be Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine the woman who's been
pulling strings behind the scenes with
people like John Walker AKA us agent and
Yelena belova not to mention the
shocking Revelation that she used to be
married to agent Ross brings up all
sorts of questions about what valve's
end game is and how Russ could play a
part in it Val's decision to have Ross
arrested and taken into custody is
actually pretty by the books given what
he does whether she feels as gives her
an advantage in her shadowy plans or she
just wants to make Ross pay for sharing
American Secrets because she's a good
CIA director isn't clear either way with
Ross now free and likely in wakanda
after being rescued by Okoye it's
natural to wonder if this could set up a
showdown between Val and the wakandans
Ross doesn't seem to especially like Val
but there is a certain familiarity there
that could be useful if and when she
stirs up trouble in the future this
could happen in the upcoming
Thunderbolts movie or another production
altogether
the introduction of Namor is a big deal
for both the world of the Black Panther
movies and the MCU as a whole especially
since he's a rare Marvel antagonist who
survives the conclusion of the film in
the end he ends up agreeing to a truce
between wakanda and talakon bringing the
fight between the two countries to an
end however the talocons are incredibly
antagonistic to wakanda and the rest of
the world throughout the film they first
kill everyone in the American research
facility searching for vibranium in the
ocean deaths and later attack wakanda
after Nakia kills a telecon while
rescuing shuri and Riri throughout the
movie Namor rails against the evils of
the surface world he wants to keep
talukan HID him from those who dwell on
land and seems prepared to kill anyone
who could compromise that objective it
seems his people agree with this stance
to the point that the truce with wakanda
frustrates at least some of them yet
when they Maura confronts him about his
decision to walk away peacefully May
more ominously claims that when the
surface world comes to wakanda wakanda
will turn to talocon now Neymar seems to
think that wakanda's resources will be
too much for the world to resist
eventually leading to a massive war only
the telecons can help them fight at that
point satello can't would have the
opportunity to bring the surface well to
its knees as they originally planned
however it's hard to imagine the whole
world openly taking on wakanda all that
wakanda would need talukan's help
against far less technologically
advanced countries on the other hand
it's undeniable that the world is
preoccupied with finding vibranium
Neymar might very well have a point
fans who are eagerly awaiting the
appearance of the X-Men in the MCU are
likely to cheer when Neymar refers to
himself as a mutant in Black Panther
wakanda forever the comics often
describe him as the first mutant so his
emergence as the mcu's first official
member of that group creates a wonderful
symmetry while there have been hints
about the existence of mutants in the
MCU before most prominently in the
Disney plus series Miss Marvel Kamala
there's something different
in your genes
like
like a mutation Neymar is the first to
identify himself this way moreover based
on the origins he shares with his
underwater Kingdom he's been around for
a very long time Neymar's introduction
suggests there could be many other
mutants in the MCU just waiting to be
revealed no plans have yet been
announced for an official MCU X-Men film
but we know Logan will be part of
Deadpool 3. what could this mean just
like the MCU has introduced several
possible members of a Young Avengers
style super team so too could the MCU
introduce mutant characters with the
goal of bringing them together in an
x-men-esque group Neymar could also play
an important role in a variety of other
outings including the mcu's upcoming
Fantastic Four film
the mid-credit scene of black panther
wakanda forever introduces a character
of Tucson son of Nakia and t'challa who
Reveals His Real Name is t'challa JR
nakira's kept her child a secret from
the wakandan people at t'challa's
request however at the country's line of
succession runs through the king then
t'challa junior is a rightful heir to
the throne sure he seems surprised but
happy to meet her nephew it's possible
her reaction is the result of relief
that there is someone else who could
ultimately be responsible for leading
wakanda obviously t'challa Jr is far too
young to take on the duties of a king
but either shuri or Nakia could act as
his regions until he's ready to fulfill
his role moreover t'challa JR could also
become the Black Panther when he's old
enough while Nakia seems to want to keep
her son in Haiti for the time being she
indicates her plan is to bring him to
wakanda eventually the question is when
will that happen even more pressingly
what will it mean for the future of
wakanda and the MCU as a whole it's
possible we won't hear about t'challa Jr
again for quite some time at that far
off Point t'challa Junior could become
the leader his father intended to become
before his untimely death but the young
boy also has the potential to cause an
enormous shake-up in the wakandan power
structure the MCU tends to be pretty
calculated in its Revelations so we're
betting that we'll see more of t'challa
Junior sooner rather than later
[Music]